you
here we go the Vanden Bosch tournament
it's a one minute er 47 have entered at
the start let's see what we get in this
one regular chess just got finished
playing a king of the hill so this is a
bit of an adjustment okay they grab the
bishop pair let's try to make use of my
lead and development it's and
convenience that night or is he going
stop Bishop c5 for one like d6 it's me
pretty painful let's take him out and
Knight d6 soon huh
stop that pawn from going any further
okay let's go here now take with the
pond now if the Queen let's play this
more positionally okay their bishops
having a tough day ah
let's take here oh I'm dropping a piece
okay alrighty here goes there there a
rook is coming to life now I'm on the g5
pawn what am i doing what am i doing oh
boy let's go here hang up where exactly
not there not there man it's not a good
move oh the Queen's gonna give a check
why was a check not thrown in I got
their queen now let's go here yeah that
actually traps their queen no it doesn't
it's me now I do want to do that get
their Queen now what an ugly game
oh my goodness ugliness ugliness
time burning stuff now time burning
stuff be sneaky with the pawn new queen
is on board
it's me back to tournament I forgot that
the bishop was ie7 I took that pod don't
take that pawn ever again you need to
count better buddy he had two defenders
you had two attackers ah okay her I only
had one defender who am I talking about
take a free night focus on this game
focus on this game who cares about that
last one okay let's try fishing pole
stuff Queen b6 if the bishop leaves the
diagonal or just focus on this a
different different twist on the fishing
pole the Queen coming out to h4 now
let's try this this way giving the piece
back maybe better just take the bishop
huh let's give this check now now the
knight is poison if the King goes to the
h-file just do that take the bishop next
maybe yeah why not and let's just do
this down in time change my mind here
watch over d5 in case of F
I can back up and I guess here it's the
only safe square take with the pawn
Bishop c5 anything down on time back
determine okay my goodness where do we
stand
efore six its top so these games are not
finishing anytime soon throw that in as
an in-betweener alright Bishop f4 mmm
let's put some pressure on this win that
pond now let's try to hang it into them
I have enough coverage so that this
isn't winning material all right so I'm
hanging on to that guy all right I have
h2 covered with my knight let's go here
actually no that is winning material
isn't it mmm I should have played night
there I was bad I didn't get anything
for losing that piece nothing all right
I got a rattle there Bishop position
it's too strong I got to get in g5 I be
square covered but it still might hit
and be good some piece here he's
probably good idea good move rook Bishop
Bishop stop King Queen g3 my pawn was
pinned all right I have to do time
burning stuff let's keep the Queen's on
just a moment ooh the whole farm fell
right there that's a tough woman it's a
real tough one okay point over one two
and that'll do it
okay back to tournament that was an ugly
game
was terrible ah man messy messy messy
game 12 10 8 8 8
ok let's try a Sicilian
maybe I'm premium free moving too much
slow it down man you have to go so fast
slow it down some okay let's try h5
stop the g4 plan let's stop g4 it's
probably too soon
G 3 H 3 and then G 4 is another idea I
guess they're going to go Kings side now
Bishop e7 I have to be prepared to take
on this square with a knight
what's that about okay we're going to
get in Knight b6 this was a very useful
tempo um actually the knight has to go
in the corner if I take like this I get
the focus on these dark squares are my
bishop covering this should be good
enough hmm
castle rook d8 and then d5 open up the
position I do have the bishop pair after
all take with the rook their queen is
close to trapped ouch oh I missed that
just drop a knight in here they resigned
back to tournament d5 as soon as that
hit was big trouble
alright oh this guy's fours arcing me
wow that's pretty crazy
quick mate let's come over here why not
open it up okay I will give some
material back they're actually really
really quick
really quick Queens off though isn't
that close to like mate when that
happens if your brews irk not not that
slow
I don't think let's see we're gonna see
they're catching up actually they are
definitely catching up I didn't want to
do that so make sure I hunt that pawn
down okay Wow
I'm actually losing I am too slow
oh boy oh it's my move I got to do this
and they could fly ah ah that's so paint
they're down on time oh my goodness
that was awful I figured if the Queens
are off ah it was just too much it's so
much easier for them to even play mmm
that's another way to look at it ah man
I'm not getting loose ha ha ha 22 18 16
14 13 I should have lost that Wow a
nail-biter how did they not pull that
last one off maybe they did that on
purpose no they would not done that they
didn't have mercy on me there no way all
right got a rebound here buddy got a
rebound got to play better chess just
play regular chess just play regular
stuff man okay let's go here
okay came away and get back wonderful
plan you're running right into f5 let's
take that
guy pins all right
develop my bishop on this square mmm
night a night on that square is good
let's get rid of him fish up little
he'll be challenged okay clean exchange
I'm up on let's hunt this guy down okay
King position pretty much cream of that
not sure where I should go with my rook
mmm-hmm rooks going to head for c4 rook
f32 here I'm floundering let's get this
move in first rook up King back rook
here this was wonderful progress what I
just did right then wonderful progress
this was beautiful technique beautiful
beautiful technique yes beautiful
technique throwing checks okay throw a
Czech trade okay I have a time edge
should do it
back to Turman oh man
twenty-five twenty two twenty eighteen
eighteen man no I'm at sixteen wow I got
to pick up the pace here get the chest
prints they hang on let's see what he
does first this is the song low attack
uh the song low attack who's familiar
with that attack who knows what I'm
talking about
watch out for the song low attack slow
this is song low slash hippo hybrid song
low hippo hybrid variation very
dangerous very very very dangerous yeah
your nights close to uh dead meat he's
close to dead meat he is dead oh my oh
my goodness check out the exchange now
I'm pre moving stuff that's unfriend
stat even a good primo oh yeah we going
right in for the kill Queen here that's
awful okay now I get to hang it you know
they're gonna anchor him in there um
only one note to do not sure if that
does no idea
alright here I guess this is bad this is
really bad
hurt and man I'm hurtin I'm hurtin Wow I
wonder if I could at some point throw
it's right at them that'd be nice there
we go my first threat well done well
done
you see what happens in their clock
ticks um you know that's what happens
it's good good things happen when you
throw threats at your opponent you
should consider it at some point hitting
their queen and there's a beastly night
beastly
I'm on the rook I'm on the pond a
dangerous one a very dangerous one
looking for made on h1 that's a fork ah
what are you doing
could you just move um push
I had the diagonal covered okay I should
have everything covered here right I
don't want that pawn 2-inch any further
why do I give that up
oh no I got a sack Oh is the time going
to run out soon
Wow unbelievable they're down at time oh
man we're at the halfway point
Oh a little less than half 14 minutes I
had no idea what was going on in that
one that was just ugliness I think I was
too flustered or something the song low
attack song low hippo hybrid look it up
google it yeah that was wonderful what I
just did there
wonderful they should be a fine home a
fine home repair my structure yes a four
versus to love it the king is a fighter
maintain that maintain the two to zero
soon three two one three two one or two
to zero straight I got three rooks three
Brooks versus two on trader Brook one
rook trade and that's over got it two to
one for the rooks push nice and easy
here we go back to tournament where are
we at 30 27 26 24 22 oh this guy again
he is flying okay it's got some serious
speed some serious speed let's challenge
that night and okay I guess they're
gonna do that huh
threatening me we doing there I'm not
gonna hurt me maybe
oh that night is dangerous man he's a
very dangerous guy kind of dropped him
back ready to sack I feel like I need to
sack here Wow
no there's so many Forks man so many
Forks everywhere so many Forks just go
right into a pin Wow
again that was maybe too soon wow that
just barely worked out just by chance
just by chance I'm getting this one Wow
thirty-two thirty thirty twenty six
twenty six twenty one who eleven minutes
speedy gonzales is up there six points
back this is this is interesting one
it's an interesting race got some strong
players up here nice V sit I need to
score a quick win did I play this guy in
the first round
yeah quick win and I'm playing something
that's very strategic okay
okay there palm structure is really
shattered on the Queen side now and a
Castle kingside a bishop breathing right
down here let's secure the f4 square
mm-hmm okay
my queen defense c2 no okay Castle I'm
not going to though Knight g5 incoming
and throw some pieces towards their king
now Knight g5 bishops kind of dead
unless the C pawn moves and they have to
move to see pawns for that to happen so
this is actually working out now h6 I
have this
and take with the pawn or the night
that's me
that was a pretty quick one back to
tournament 32 out of 34 30 to 30 30 okay
the whole pick is up there chess Prince
again uh-huh okay another song low
attack
let's Castle queenside yeah we're going
to Castle queenside I don't have a safe
kingside structure mm let's take another
pawn and I'm going to take that night
right now actually
it's Castle if he moves the structure is
split after defend against a to try to
light square bishop s' let's get f5 and
two passers they're beautiful aren't
they ah let's go here grab this pawn
bishops a tall upon tall upon let's take
what this guy mm shouldn't have done
that
I realize what their idea was with that
move should challenge their bishop he's
really strong let's cut him off and keep
a closing kurma shup here grab this pawn
next hmm okay I actually have this move
no I don't because there's a knight c3
move okay I cover a3 hitting the night
okay I just want to take
Kim stop the main thread on b2 up a
piece at the end of this clock is fine
Queen trade or not she's going to be
central very soon on D on e5 they
resigned back to term in 36 34 34 33 28
okay less than 8 minutes and this one
well how many more games maybe it's free
for four more games let's see hmm I
thought a moment for maybe I thought
about maybe berserk and I don't know
maybe too early to try that let's see I
think it's important to just keep the
streak going don't want to miss that up
so let's go here anticipating a pinned
against my knight let's go here I'll
have to worry about night g5 since the
knight developed initially to e2 let's
clean up spending some time here night
b4 is a good square it's a for MU is
quite weakening
oh wow they're really spending a lot of
time here maybe a bug or something
what's the bishop going to do take and
push okay see for Bishop is close to
trapped is he trapped they have c3 rook
takes here's on my bishop point at f2
still on the bishop mmm let's go here
I'm on f2 now so this is a really
serious hitting the Queen discoveries
now tough to save the queen
okay now we have this and yes is really
difficult now for them
Bishop
check in here get the rook mate in a
couple so I may eat next close back to
tournament they're down on time 40 38 38
less than six minutes left forty thirty
eight thirty thirty four thirty hmm
okay alrighty leave 411 I want to go see
five all right get me five break in all
right hey let's go for that and it's
pointed their king
all right yeah let's do something direct
no look at some pieces over here let's
just take him out actually whoo
let's hang onto him and now we're
pushing h4 next just side stepped out
keep the Queens on the board let's break
this open could have considered a night
sack mate soon one of these two and it
can't be avoided tonight next all right
that was pretty quick back to term at 42
I have a one-point lead yiiikes 42 41 40
35 too close it's way too close
oh man okay yeah sure we're gonna go
it's silly in the fishing pole call on a
fishing pole for a quick quick uh it's
it's rare ah one step okay I can still
work with that I'll only go there when
I'm kicked all right now we're gonna do
this stop the night getting Knight f5
okay here we go
okay my squared bishop is a beast he's a
beast queenside castle don't do that
big problem on the light squares let's
see could be very dangerous
I'm going to play Knight there aren't
they
hi bishop c6 fortunately fortunately
they're going to get a queen trade I
gotta get rid of their night he was
going to be too strong here
rook there okay this is trouble
this is trouble gotta get this pawn
yikes this is going to be very difficult
to win very very difficult they're all
kind of okay that was maybe a bit too a
bit too soon there's that move isn't
there okay that was actually a bit
helpful check okay
this is going to be a time time race Oh
actually I'm getting the rook that was
very fortunate if 4946 4946 and down
three two minutes left
I'm still on streak so four points will
do it hopefully uh somebody beats him
he's probably berserk huh I don't know
if I could get two more games in after
their king I can also do sure I can what
am I saying
I'm dropping my knight this is such ugly
chess such ugly chess my rook has been
hanging for forever in the corner no
one's gonna see it though no one Oh pin
a knight
there you go he's out of the pin babysit
upon okay discovered check mates please
yes a quick win can I get one more game
in one more game they let in their clock
tick no way back to tournament fifty yes
he lost but he's ready to win maybe he's
playing right now ah fishing pole this
is gonna be the last game for me oh
let's see let's see let's get d5 in all
right this is turning it to more like a
French now um let's go here keep
pressure on e5 let's get in 94 it should
be pretty good right um let's develop
need to get castled and that move huh
that move no no on that pawn runaway
this game is not finishing so let's just
see how it plays out hopefully didn't
win we're gonna see we're going to see
I'm on c2 crashing through there a queen
trade no maybe I should have okay I'm on
this threatens me that is me who I got
it Oh
ah man
what a close one my goodness
50 49 ah any of two losses at the end
and it's tough she's bruised arcing
every game not every game but enough
fifty forty nine forty five thirty nine
thirty four thirty what am I saying
fifty nine forty nine forty five 3937 oh
man
sixty-five were in this one page one can
you see everything there you go you
should see everything now that's page
page one two three four five six seven
all right to the sixty five of you that
took part in this one good games oh wow
that was a nail-biter that was really
close what a what a nice mix of really
strong players in that one very nice to
see all righty
you